one of the most sinister characters
in the greek tragedy that has been the
trump presidency
is without a doubt donald trump's press
secretary
kelly mcinanni who also plays a dual
role on television where sometimes she's
not white house press secretary
but instead she's merely a campaign
advisor for donald trump's presidential
campaign
yesterday i played clips for you of
kaylee
on fox news monday night saying things
about voter fraud
as a campaign advisor and then tuesday
morning i mean we're talking 12 hours 11
hours later maybe even
on a different fox fox show fox and
friends saying
when asked about those claims oh you
know you've got to talk to the campaign
about that because today
i'm here as white house press secretary
how convenient how convenient well
it's this completely kafka-esque
situation that they've created
it's memetic quite frankly and here is
kaylee once again last night
on sean hannity's program holding up now
i guess these are ballots uh previously
she's held
up reams of paper sometimes she'll hold
up a book
or a three-ring binder and this time
it's a ballad or a paper
with a lot of sharpie circles on it and
there's there's something particularly
ironic about this one take a look
like this where they actually list out
all of the circles are different ballot
numbers
they've written the specific ballot
number down
that was dated january 1st 1900 for
someone who didn't
so the absolute hilarity is that now
without any sensible legal argument left
to make
with no credible path to overturning the
results in even
a single state never mind the multiple
states they would need to overturn for
for donald trump to win on the basis of
non-existent voter fraud
now she is relegated to talking about
what are essentially confusing layouts
on pieces of paper
and those who have been following
politics for some time may remember
the irony of this because back in the
year 2000
the florida results were the question
with hanging chads and these butterfly
ballots where
the candidate's name was on one side and
there would be an arrow pointing to the
other side and it was unclear okay
that was when republicans didn't want to
do a recount
that was when republicans didn't want to
really look closely and ascertain
what was the intention of this voter
in filling out this ballot they said no
no no stop the recount
secretary of state catherine florida
secretary of state katherine harris
getting involved the supreme court
getting involved now
after all of their other arguments have
failed and been dismissed by courts as
having no merit
kaylee mcinanny is relegated to saying
the layout is confusing there's stuff
all over the page
look i've circled it with a sharpie
they're pathetic
kaylee continues with her various pieces
of paper
check it out exactly there's no praise i
mean this is one
county here one county where you have
literally hundreds of pages in one
county
um in wayne county detroit all across
the country
this is uh i tweeted about this this is
the gish gallop in paper form that's
what this has been
from kaylee mcinanni and and others who
just hold up papers
gish this is actually this may be
instructive to some gish gallup is a
debate term
okay and what it means is
when a debater tries to overwhelm their
opponent
just by making lots of arguments even if
the arguments are bogus right you make
many arguments it's quantity over
quality you make a lot of arguments in a
debate
without regard for the accuracy or the
strength of the arguments
that's called a gish gallop this is gish
gallop by paper
using an excessive number of pieces of
paper to make an argument
based on the idea that you have so many
pieces of paper
with no regard to the accuracy or
strength or validity
or or relevance of any of those pieces
of paper and that's exactly what we've
seen we've seen some of these pieces of
paper
uh say uh that the the poll workers
didn't like how they were treated that
somebody was rude to them
we've seen these pieces of paper uh
refer
to towns that aren't even in the states
where they claim to be indicating there
was voter fraud so for example
there was i'm trying to remember now
there was a filing made
in either pennsylvania or georgia which
said
look at the fraud in michigan in these
five
towns and none of those five towns were
in michigan the five towns were in
minnesota
so it's gish gallop by paper and then
here's just one more
where kaylee again pulls out this term
she created
electoral epidemic which is it should be
seen as a joke anyway
take a look stay pandemic and created an
electoral epidemic
but we are fighting new lawsuit today
and wisconsin just filed 366 pages
detailing how wisconsin law was violated
so these people are
well listen i mean if the lawsuit is 366
pages
it must be substantive right and every
time i hear that phrase electoral
epidemic
i think yes it was an epidemic of people
voting in record numbers more people
than ever before
decided to go and vote that's the
epidemic by the way
can you believe it's already been a
month since the election it it's
stunning how time is flying and the good
news of that
is trump will be gone from the white
house before you know it
one of our sponsors today is helix sleep
and it's a sponsor
i'm thrilled about because i sleep on a
helix mattress
at home and it's just the perfect
mattress one of the best things about
helix is
you don't have to guess which mattress
do i need which one will be good for me
you take their famous sleep quiz on
their website you tell them your body
type
your sleeping position your back pain
issues you might have and they will pair
you with a mattress that will be perfect
for you
i took the sleep quiz the mattress they
suggested was exactly what i needed i
often get too hot at night
the mattress keeps me cool it's not too
soft it's not too firm the texture is
right
and i've just been getting way better
sleep you only buy a mattress
every decade or so don't get stuck with
something that's not perfect for you and
all helix mattresses come with a 10 year
warranty
and they'll even come to your house and
pick it up within a hundred days
if you don't love it but i think you
will all of my viewers will get up to
200
off your order and you'll get two super
premium pillows
for free when you go to the link right
underneath this video